foreign
is in Philadelphia hi Leon welcome to
the Ramsay show hi Dave hi John how you
all doing better than we deserve what's
up
hey I was calling today to see if uh we
should allow finances to stop my wedding
plans
that's a broad question can you tell us
more
yeah absolutely so my fiance and I have
been together for a long time she's
desired to get married more than I have
or more more time than I have
um it took our return to faith and our
my fiance's bravery during the pandemic
to really open my eyes to marriage
um
our opinions diverge in one area
um and and that's our approach to
marriage I'm more pragmatic with my
Approach
and she's more idealistic
um in preparation to in preparations to
get married I did some math
and uh realized that in getting married
um some of our expenses will increase
significantly in particular our health
coverage
um my fiance uh qualifies for a no-cost
medical insurance right now through the
state and um
in the event that we do get married or
when we do get married
um that that expense will increase
significantly it'll go from about
um 104 a month to about 510 a month my
employer funded uh health insurance to
add a spouse that it it jumped
significantly so what's your what's your
household income
um we're at about 62 000 a year you're
not honestly honestly asking us if your
wife is your wife if her becoming your
wife's worth 4 800 a year
well it's it's a little more than that
yeah it might be forty eight hundred and
fourteen dollars come on super nerd
really
well the deductibles will also double
you're killing me
listen hey here's the deal no you should
not get married
you should not no absolutely not
if you're gonna nickel and dime your
relationship with this woman that has
has suggested she wants to spend the
rest of her life with you even the way
you said I came around to marriage
because I saw she was Brave and
um something that like
I want the hounds of Hell holding you
back from wanting to be with this person
forever
and forty eight hundred dollars dude
I've seen guys way make way like making
stupid Financial moves because they were
so head over heels they were going to
marry somebody that I had to say whoa
whoa slow down
forty eight hundred dollars sounds like
you are looking for a mathematical
reason to not do this is what it sounds
like
um It Isn't So we have a child together
okay and um we kind of went went about
our our family a little bit backwards
um so we purchased the house we have a
family together and it really is our
plan to be a single single income
household
um with with me working and and she's
staying home and helping to raise our
son with me
um so it's it's not just the I I know
that if we pursued
um plans in a more traditional way Leon
how old are you 40. or your mom and dad
still married
No nasty divorce
no um I was young
hurt you though
um yeah yeah definitely did and um I do
think it had an impact on my view of
marriage in terms of you know
what so you're looking for a way to
intellectualize
a spiritual and emotional decision
yes
and um
you're you're the best John's point is
the best thing you can do and it will
actually cause the math to work out
there's an odd odd piece of uh irony
here but the best thing you can do is go
all in it's time to get off the ladder
time to stop painting painter get off
the ladder it's time to do it dude you
have a baby you own a house in every
form you're married except in your
emotions where you have finally let go
of that last little piece of control and
that last little hurt little boy named
Leon from his mom and dad's thing and it
scared him and it hurt him and that
doesn't make you bad it doesn't make you
weak it just makes you a human
and it's time to let go of all that and
marry this woman and enjoy her and enjoy
life together and enjoy a wonderful
future and lean into the emotional
relational spiritual part of that and
then there is actual data that's called
the marriage advantage
that's uh that shows statistically that
married couples end up with a higher
probability of wealth and net worth and
a higher net worth than singles
particularly singles shacked up
and uh so the data is actually there the
research is actually there to back this
up that's right and it goes back to you
and I were having a conversation earlier
um on another show about
um
Sharon's work at home allowed I mean
whether it's somebody contributing
directly cash into the account or
whether somebody's creating a platform
for
uh somebody else to to repel off the
side into
um man it it works out that way it just
does yeah you're you're gonna you're
gonna Prosper more than the
supposed loss that you have identified
yeah and mathematically that's going to
end up being true
um I can't I can't it's
um
difficult to put actual actual examples
in place today
but I do know that the research says
that and I do know that my 30 plus years
of doing this helping people with money
shows that a fully committed couple in a
marriage that have shared goals and
vision
and are both working towards the same
thing and um one of them's neither one
of them are dead weight they both are
are contributors to the discussion
contributors to the dream that there's
just a trim you know the career is
better the health is better the um
obesity is lower the uh blood pressure
is lower the everything and all that all
of that by the way ends up affecting
your dollars and cents absolutely so
there's a whole thing there and then of
course this idea that that you know two
horses pulling together in tandem one
plus one equals more than two and we all
know that's called Synergy yeah that's
right uh and if you notice if you listen
back to the call Dave I it's an old
counselor trick but when somebody comes
and asks like I'm kind of stuck I don't
know if I should do this I should do
this
if you'll just say well go and break up
sometimes they'll exhale and sometimes
they'll come back and be like I'm not
breaking up and there's your answer
right and so there's a push it's it's
just an old then you're not ready to get
married and if the first impulse is yes
I am then there now you've
intellectualized it you need to get on
that track and if it's you're right I
don't need to get married then you've
answered your own question yeah but you
also by asking these questions Leon
you've identified some things you all
have the opportunity to work on some
healing in absolutely that'll uh that'll
release a lot of positive stuff in your
relationships and in your money